il ya quelques années des copains ont
passé un week end inoubliable
cette année ils ont réaménagé dans la
ville de leur enfance
excusez moi une petite seconde
je crois que ta mère est là elle a l'air
très en colère pour se concentrer sur ce
qui compte vraiment un endroit idéal
pour élever une famille allait
tranquillement à l'école en vélo on peut
pas le faire à élever heureusement qu'il
se passe jamais rien eu d'un dc
à mon tour non je suis déjà leurs
enfants grandissent bien ce que j'aurai
démunis comme maman jamais je veux pas
que dans les pattes ça mais on ne
grandit pas sans histoire j'en reviens
pas qu'on ait sauté d'ici et vous êtes
en territoire cap ait à sygma rôle on se
calme le minet propre sur lui quoi quoi
les gars sympa vos petites salutations
nous on en a d'autres regardez columbia
pictures présent
ouah
oui chérie ça va tout va comme tu veux
on va pas vous retardez onu à la tenue
vous êtes tous des gros nuls
à
jeu qu'à l'intérieur de toi copains pour
toujours deux canaux entier la sto
qui reste prochainement